[Music]
good evening I have a few announcements
tonight the first of which is that as
many of you know we record these talks
and at first we had them the videos only
available to members and last year we
made the last the most recent 12 videos
available to the public and then the
back catalogue available to all members
and what we saw is that a lot more
people started seeing the videos of
course and actually a lot more people
became members so we we thought we might
lose members by doing this but because
it turns out all of you members how many
of you are members in this room thank
you very much that all of you who are
members really are members to support
long now and less to get through gated
content so working with our media
partner for a TV as of today we're
making the entire back catalogue free to
everyone
and so we really appreciate your support
as members and hopefully we'll continue
to have it and then we have another
announcement also working with fora is a
new way to consume some of that video
this is a series about long-term
thinking the idea of the future is a
much longer idea than it used to be it's
sort of the interplay of ideas and
instruments and data not just the
technology it's not just us our minds
not just guy it's all three together and
old philanthropy is fragmented and
short-term the new philanthropy needs to
be connected
[Music]
story is so important to us because it
is thing that we have been using since
the door
of humanity to become more than just one
person
[Music]
yeah so this is a little sneak peek
we're gonna be making the official
announcement later this week when this
video rolls on the on the air but to
give you an idea of how the app works
it's it's you can just search for long
now on the iTunes Store right now and
you can get this on all your iOS devices
as well as on Apple TV we have about 50
of the most recent videos on the app now
because that's when we started filming
in HD going and we'll continue to add
those going forward and you can access
the entire catalog back catalog online
on our website so thank you very much
for all of your support and hopefully
you can now watch more of the videos in
more formats than and ways to watch them
on your couch with your iPad than before
and as many of you know we always do a
long short before these talks and
sometimes they're very difficult to
select but tonight's short film about
long-term thinking was an easy one to
find enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
okay signature all right here's the deal
marshmallow for you you can either wait
and I'll give you another one if you
wait or you can eat it now when I come
back I'll give you another one so then
you'll have to but stay in here and stay
in the chair till I come back okay all
right
[Music]
I'm gonna go do something and then I'll
come back
[Music]
[Music]
all right so it's up to you you can have
it now or you can wait okay I'll be back
stay in the chair okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I'm gonna leave and then
I'll come back okay so you can even eat
it right now or you can wait either way
okay okay
[Music]
how'd you do did you do good you did you
wouldn't need it in me yeah so don't
tell you to give me another one okay now
you can have both
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
keep your eyes on the prize I'm Stuart
brand from long now foundation these
question cards every now and then I
repeat it's something that's worth
knowing the questions that you write the
way they get up here is they go through
two screens one of those Kevin Kelly
sitting down here in the dark so the
things which are written short and
really really legible a whole essay you
know a little tough and then he prepares
his stack which he gives to me I come up
here and I haven't seen it before I'm on
the stage with the speaker and I don't
want to be too rude to the speaker who's
reading your essay so again short
legible helps the speaker tonight is
gonna make a pretty brief presentation
covering the subject which he's got a
glimpse of here and then once they have
an ongoing discussion with me and with
you so keep your questions coming during
his presentation and then keep them
coming as we proceed to talk now these
are called seminars about long term
thinking but more than most this is a
going to be on thinking to a seminar
about long term behavior and a person
who's been studying that his entire life
is Walter Mischel thank you very much
it's a pleasure to be here the little
film that you saw is not one that I made
but it was made I think it was made at
Stanford and it's got quite a few
inaccuracies that I'd like to point out
to him
I mean the first thing is these
marshmallows which are now surrounded by
a halo of light actually enormous and
the ones that we used when we used
marshmallows were deliberately very tiny
now this is very important because the
whole idea is to create an intense
counseling for the child so it's a
choice that is a tough tough choice
because you had this little one or the
two da let me show you what the actual
setup is that we used it's in this
picture and what you're seeing is
there's a child here this is actually
from a study that we did in South
America years after the original studies
at the big nursery school at Stanford
University which were done in the period
from about 1964 to 1974 I was at
Stanford for 21 years beginning in 1962
and then I moved to Columbia University
where I still am currently so what
you're seeing here is a little kid in
this case somewhere around age 5 towards
6 who is waiting with two tiny things in
front of her actually not so tiny in
this case because what she chose were
Oreo cookies so very often we don't use
marshmallows particularly the mom said
Stanford had a big thing about how many
of the children were not allowed to eat
stuff without like that without having a
toothbrush at hand
so it's a methodological problems of
that kind that make rigorous research
difficult
so and the child has a bell that's true
in all of the studies that we ran and
that other people who have been using
the procedure for research do so at any
point the child can ring the bell and
bring the researcher bags it's also very
important to build a trust relationship
with the child first so that she
believes that you're really coming back
that's a fundamental and what the child
has on the tray in front of her are two
Oreo cookies on the right side and one
Oreo cookie on the left side so all the
goodies that she's chosen from a whole
array of possibilities are right there
the conflict is intense and the question
is how long does she wait until she
either begins to eat the thing or to
ring the bell to bring the researcher
back and as I say it's very important to
have a trust relationship with the child
and to make sure that what she's waiting
for is something that she really wants
so one of the important questions is
does it matter is that him is it
interesting I got interested in this
topic really I stumbled into it at the
kitchen table on the Stanford campus
where I lived at the time with with
three daughters who were four or five
and six they were very closely spaced
and I became fascinated by the question
of what makes it possible for kids to
begin to have self-control for any of us
to begin to delay gratification to give
up something that we want immediately
for the sake of something that's
temporarily distant and for kids fifteen
minutes can seem like an eternity for me
- 15 minutes can seem like an eternity
so the the question that I realized I
couldn't answer at the time was what
goes on in a human head that makes this
possible and I didn't have a clue
so I wanted to develop a method in which
we could see what do children actually
do that makes it possible for them so
this began in no way as a test I still
don't think it's good to call it a test
it's the media that call it the test I
call it a method or a measure to to have
a measure in which we can see what the
natural ways are in which people begin
to manage this and what we found we're
really the diverse strategies that kids
use for this purpose but it does matter
it turns out it does matter not nearly
as much as the medium make it out to
matter but it matters there are
correlations there are connections
they're not they're only correlations
and they're often statistically
significant but they're not overwhelming
they they are sufficient to have an idea
that on the whole it's a pretty good
idea to be able to delay gratification
even when you're very young but it is
not dearly sufficiently strong to think
that how long a particular child is
going to wait for the two cookies or the
two marshmallows or the two M&Ms or
whatever is really going to be able to
strongly predict the individuals future
you can say something about group
effects but you can say virtually
nothing about the individual child on
the whole though they did when we
retested them in some of the studies
have higher SAT scores they had better
social cognitive functioning this is
when we looked at them as that young
adolescents they yielded less the
temptation and had more grit they were
less distractible called better with
stress felt better with frustration this
is sort of on the whole at age 4
there was a reasonably strong prediction
to body mass index 30 years later
and consistent self-control that is if
we take kids who are consistently on a
variety of measures as they're growing
up able to delay gratification and
compare them to a group that is at the
low end consistently on diverse measures
of self-regulation we found when these
kids came back at age forty to
forty-five so these are studies just
done about five or six years ago to the
Stanford campus and were tested both on
cognitive measures and in the fMRI
itself that there were distinctive
expected differences in brain activation
areas when they tried to inhibit
responses to attractive or hard stimuli
while they were in the scanner so on the
whole high self-control people tend to
be more able to inhibit hot responses
the question that I think is really
important is does the lay ability early
in life protect as well as predict does
it have a protective effect for example
against excessive acting out bullying
extreme aggression depression borderline
personality in vulnerable individuals
and on the whole again just correlations
and not all that high but statistically
better than chance the answer is yes is
in aggressive young children and
adolescents yes in adults with high
anxiety about rejection yes in
individuals prone to develop borderline
features of personality yes in those
prone to obesity yes let me just pause
now before going on to some of these
findings to tell you about what the
spontaneous strategies are that kids
actually use you saw some of them in the
film but one that is for me particularly
memorable with Oreo cookies is a young
guy very neatly dressed nice necktie
white shirt beautifully combed hair who
examined the door to make sure it was
shut checked it very carefully open the
first Oreo cookie licked out the entire
inside closed it immediately replaced
Utley identical position where it was
took the second Oreo cookie gave it the
identical treatment licked out the
inside replaced the cover putting back
in exactly the same place went on and
did the same with the third and then
struck a pose of utter innocence looking
looking at the door so to me quite
remarkable also was that when I
presented that information and showed
that video at a target Columbia
University the Provost shouted in joy
give that boy a scholarship to come here
which I thought was a somewhat strange
moral reaction to the behavior at hand
but now let me let me give you an
example of the protective effects of
being able to delay gratification
take the a dimension of personality that
I think is very important because it's
so widely shared which is the tendency
to be anxious about the possibility of
getting rejected which a lot of us have
so it's defined really as a tendency to
easily perceive rejection and to
overreact by becoming aggressive or
withdrawn or depressed that have lowered
self-esteem and essentially to behave in
a way that makes rejection a
self-fulfilling prophecy
you're worried about it so much that you
behave in a way to be sure to get it
now this is a summary of a lot of
research and what it shows you there is
only one unhappy face right that bred
unhappy face in the lower left hand box
there you see it and in the it is the
condition in which kids in preschool
were showing low delay ability but as
adults they had high rejection
sensitivity and so what these kids as as
in the follow ups as adults were showing
were lower positive functioning lower
self-esteem lower educational levels and
higher cocaine crack use not that there
was a huge amount of it but there was
some of it so the protective effects of
of delay ability are quite substantial
and then at the bottom of that graph you
seeing middle school follow-up of kids
that were tested in very different
circumstances not on an elite college
campus but in the South Bronx of New
York where these kids from them really
from the bottom of the socio-economic
divide who had the combination of strong
tendencies towards feeling rejection
sensitivity and being anxious about it
and low delay ability we're in this
vulnerable cell with lower self-worth
lower cell lower self acceptance lower
peer acceptance and higher aggression so
the point I'm making is that to me it is
more important that delay ability
has protective effects and the inability
to delay gratification has a quite
serious potential negative effects but
the key question that has motivated this
research for all these years
and that has caught on in many other
labs is to understand the mechanisms the
mental mechanisms and the brain
mechanisms that make delay either hard
or easy and that is what I think is the
most important thing to come out of
those experiments and what they showed
very clearly also is that delay skills
cognitive skills that make it possible
for kids and adults to wait can be
taught this I think is the most
important slide that I'm going to show
you and it is that the human brain has
really in it too closely interacting
systems one is the hot system it's the
limbic system it's a goal system it's
emotional it's simple it's reflexive
it's fast you saw it and the kids who
shove the stuff into their mouths so
fast its amygdala centered it develops
early in life and very importantly it is
accentuated by stress it is increased by
stress and it is fundamentally the thing
that creates stimulus control where our
marshmallows our cookies our liquor is
controlling us we're not controlling it
the other system in the brain is a cool
system or a no system it's a cognitive
system it's complex it's reflective it
allows us to give ourselves self
instructions and to take the future and
future consequences into account its
frontal lobe and hippocampus centred it
develops later in life it is attenuated
by stress
and it's fundamental for self-control so
the issues in making self-control
possible is that when people are living
under conditions of high stress the hot
system becomes dominant and the cool
system goes down or doesn't even develop
well and this is critically important
for educational purposes it's critically
important for how we think about our
children and how we think about the
future it's critically important I think
for how we think about ourselves and it
has clear implications for what we need
to do if we want to be more able to take
the future into account which is this
that by changing how we mentally
represent the objects of desire by
changing how we mentally represent them
we can change what their effect is on us
for example if the kids are queued
before they start to wait if you want to
when you want to you can think about how
yummy and chewy and delicious the
marshmallows are the bell is rung within
moments if you think on the other hand
if you want to while you're waiting how
the marshmallows are puffy and round
like clouds or cotton balls the same
child who would ring the bell within 30
seconds under the yummy and chewy
priming is going to be able to wait up
to 15 minutes so critically important is
how is the object of desire the thing
that is pulling the response mentally
represented if the kids are waiting for
pretzels are the cue to think ahead of
time how salty and crunchy it is the
bell rings if they're thinking about an
abstract or cool terms pretzels are thin
like little sticks they can wait a long
time
same child this is a summary of a lot of
studies that essentially manipulate
whether or not the rewards are
represented in cooler abstract terms or
in hot arousing terms and it's clear
that the late time hugely depends on the
nature of that mental representation and
if we can represent it one way we can
represent it the other way too so it
makes it something that we don't have to
be the victims of but that we can
actually learn to regulate and control
for me a very powerful single example
that I want to share with you is a study
in which we suggested to the children
ahead of time if you want to when you
want to you can make it isn't make
believe that it isn't really there that
it's just a picture you know what a
picture is yes a picture is something
with a frame around it yeah so if you
want to when you want to while you're
waiting you can make believe it's just a
picture put a frame around it in your
head okay and the same child who when
she's looking at it and thinking that
it's real rings the bell within moments
is able to wait 14 minutes 13 minutes 15
minutes quite a long time when I asked
Amy in this case how do you explain this
how come you you waited here but you
didn't wait there and she had I thought
a wonderfully clear answer you can't eat
a picture that is she understood and
grasped the importance of the change in
the representation so the basic
principle that comes out of this for
educational purposes or for long-term
thinking is that what is critical is to
cool the now through distraction through
self distancing the kids push it away
they play with their ear canals they
play with their nasal canals they
pretend that their toes which
California were beautifully exposed and
their thumbs and so on piano keys they
get involved in dialogues in which
they're giving themselves self
instructions and they're mouthing the
instructions there are endless ways in
which the kids are illustrating the
fundamental critical strategies that in
turn are teachable if there's a major
finding that comes out not just the from
my research but from research on mind
brain behavior relations in the last 30
years it is that self-regulation
emotional regulation delay of
gratification will power depends on
cognitive skills and motivation and that
by changing how we represent our
temptations cognitively we can use the
cool system to regulate the hot system
the value of self-control acting is
pretty evident and I don't want to dwell
on it for long it's critical for
emotional intelligence for empathy it
enables a real choice we control our
marshmallows they don't control us it
increases our sense of freedom and
agency it's we who decide when Turing
the bellman went to sell free board but
I want to also emphasize that a life
without the hot system is as sad as the
one without the cool system that is we
also have to know when it is time to
ring the bell and when it is time to
allow ourselves to have the pleasures of
life is it all pre-wired it's a question
that is often asked particularly by the
media your future in a marshmallow was a
heading on a regular lab interview to
which my emphatic answer is absolutely
not and it's the reason that I wrote the
marshmallow test mastering self-control
to try to have overcome that serious
misperception attention control strategy
and cognitive transformations to cool
the immediate temptations and heat the
delayed consequences is what's important
I'd like to give you a brief example
from my own life
when I was 32 years old I was severely
addicted to cigarettes to tobacco I
smoked three packs a day I supplemented
it with a pipe I felt that was very
professorial at that time smoking was
allowed even at Stanford University and
I parade up and down the podium and so
on with them with the pipe I realized of
course that the Surgeon General's
reports were coming out so I had the
information I knew that there were
future consequences that there was
increasing evidence that there could be
cancer that there could be all kinds of
negative effects on my life and I
proceeded to completely ignore them I
realized that I might have a problem
when I found myself in the shower one
day with the lead pipe in my mouth so
this gave me some concern but I have
very good psychological immune system
and I was able to rationalize my way out
of that and it made no difference soon
after that I had an experience which is
walking in the hallways of the Stanford
Medical School
I saw a man on a gurney being wheeled
through the hall and his head was shaved
with little green marks little green X's
and his chest was bare with little green
X's and I asked the nurse what's going
on with him and she said well those
green marks the places where the
radiation is going I couldn't shake the
image because what that image did for me
is it made hot the delayed consequences
and holding on to that image
every time namely every three minutes
that I was ready to take an
the cigarette while at the same time
changing the representation of the
cigarette from something that was
terrific and the pipe is something that
was professorial to two sources of acute
poisoning made the change possible and I
have not smoked anything since then
while completely retaining the
conviction that if I took a cigarette
this evening I would be back on it again
so the the point that I want to make is
that if we're going to talk seriously
about taking long-term consequences like
climate change into account we've got to
make them hot we have to really make
them hot and that's not easy to do but
and one of the reasons that it's not
easy to do is because that limbic system
that hot system which activates
automatically when we have high stress
is there for good reason it saves us on
the highway because we immediately
reflexively throw on the brakes when
cumin something is coming at us and it's
terrific if we're dealing with snakes or
it's terrific if we're in a situation
where lions are on oncoming but most of
the time those are not the challenges
that we face currently consequently the
critical thing is to enhance and develop
the cool system and to be able to use it
when it comes to considering long term
consequences so the personal
implications of this line of research
arranged from teaching self-control
skills and keep schools those are
knowledge is power program schools that
are very importantly being experimented
with in the Bronx of New York the public
policy in narrowing the economic divide
can make a difference I think it can the
fuel the human brain has far more
plasticity than has long been assumed we
don't have to be the victims of our bio
chicle and social biographies that's at
the personal level but what I want to
focus on for the rest of the evening
with steward is what are the wider
implications of this for the issues that
are of concern to this group and to
society the hot brain is ideal for
coping with snakes and so on
but we're no longer in the Pleistocene
but it's indifferent to long-term
consequences from the ultimate effects
of tobacco to the ultimate effects of
climate change and it misleads us
tremendously in our assessment of risks
whether in personal decisions business
decisions policy decisions educational
decisions so the question that I want to
have us thinking about for the rest of
the evening if not longer is can the
marshmallow lessons help us use the cool
brain to cope with the future disasters
that can lie ahead if we don't thank you
very much
I think have a seat we'll carry on very
legible thank you when you were 33 and
having your experience at Stanford
Medical School with the guy with the
green X's you had done this work already
with kids in the marshmallows no when I
was 33 was exactly when the work started
to begin mm-hmm was there a connection
between your figuring out what to do
about nicotine and what to do I'm sure
there was a connection no question that
there was a connection with two with two
aspects of my life one is the is the
struggle with the tobacco and the other
one is to see what was happening to my
three kids as they went through this
transformation from being really totally
adorable absolutely impossible I mean
all the things that kids are but utterly
unable to regulate or control themselves
and then in such a short time in such a
very short time within the first two
years to have really their own agenda
you know their own their own plans their
own sense their own will intuition the
sense of what they wanted to do what
they could do in the in the third year
it wasn't really still quite clear they
were stumbling around that these ideas
of what they wanted to do and so on but
they didn't have the strategies and then
this remarkable thing happens in the
fourth and fifth year where the
strategies begin to develop and if you
ask them how to do it for example if you
if you put them in situations where they
have a choice
it would be easier to wait for those
things if they're there like that or if
you put the cover on them when they are
about three and a half they often say
it'll be easy if I just can see them and
then immediately take them by the time
they're at the end of the fourth year
and into the fifth year they're
beginning to consistently say cover
month and and attempt to do that what
you don't see in the film that we played
but what you do see in the films that I
can't show because research restrictions
prevent them from being shown right
is kids hiding covering their eyes
turning away and that works I do that
works quite quite well and giving
themselves self instructions that take
them out of the situation and that allow
them to distract so that even if they
objects out there and uncovered they're
not focusing on them they're you know
singing their little songs are playing
with their toes and so on well yeah I
mean you had the perfect scientific
experiment going on in your home of
these daughters okay they're all the
same gender there are three four and
four or five and six I guess well at
three you know you can see the
confusions at four you begin to get a
clearer picture but five that really
happened and it's at six it's it's
pretty much done so what you're calling
executive function is basically coming
into play is there actual brain
development going on and creates an
enormous brain development is going on
and however if you're looking at the
development of the cool system it really
doesn't come fully in until people are
in there somewhere in their 20s
so the understanding well yeah I inside
in some cases it doesn't fully develop
until they're in their 80s
if that were you I mean you were I guess
a psychologist professionally at that
time or you were a child psychologist or
was oh I never knew what kind of
psychologist that was really I my work
has crossed the area I was trained in
clinical psychology okay and clinical
psychology was what drove me into the
field but then I became very interested
in developmental questions I became
interested in the cognitive issues about
how the mind and brain work I became
very interested in personality and who
we are in the structure of personality
one of the reasons that that links very
importantly to what we're talking about
tonight is because when you look closely
at people's self control patterns the
superficial impression that we have is
all that person this terrific itself
control this one has none people
describe themselves as saying you know
lucy has willpower
I have no willpower these are quite
inaccurate descriptions of far more
accurate analysis would show that we all
have hot spots whether it's cigarettes
whether it's marshmallows whether it's
Oreo cookies whether it's out temper and
therefore the first step in any Addie at
the individual level at the personal
level in any effort to to achieve better
self-regulation better self control is
to identify where do you need it
where are your hotspots once they're
identified it becomes possible to use
its then plans if my hot spot gets
activated then I you know you have some
kind of workaround yeah then then you
have a strategy a plan in place that
becomes automatic and it allows you to
get out of the hole so we're going back
and forth between talking about kids and
grown-ups itself well this is the
fundamentals are not different not
different I mean the the objects the
marshmallows change The Temptations
change your marshmallow was the pipe in
the the cigarettes and so on at one
point yes among others what we saw in
this wonderful brief presentation is
clearly the work of actually many
decades and I'm curiously the sort of
sequence of what did you get right away
and what took a while to emerge I mean
some of the things having to do a brain
function and so on must have come later
much later I mean what emerged for me
what was really exciting to me was to to
to see and test the cognitive skills
that made it either impossible for the
kid the lack of cognitive skills that
made it impossible for them to control
themselves even when they really much
wanted to and the motivation was high
and and the skills that were highly
teachable that go from the earliest
which is distract which every parent
knows that a terrific way to help kids
who are in under high stress and having
colleague or whatever problems is to try
to help them distract themselves and
kids learn as their first sapphire yeah
to to to get off it to or you know do a
rattle or do something do a mobile or do
something to get them distracted which
is what they spontaneously do when you
actually see what they're doing but then
it goes from in the in those years from
four to six it goes from self
distraction to learning how to do
abstraction my abstraction I mean to
cool the thing by pretending it's not
there by by focusing on its cool
features not it's hot features by
stopping to think and focus on the yummy
chewy
appetite of qualities and to get off
that and
- instead sort of turn away from the
objects of desire check every once in a
while to make sure that they're still
there but then distract yourself and
keep going so one of the previous
speakers in this series was Daniel
Kahneman who put quite a blurb on your
book how does your hot and cool mental
activity relate to his system on the
system - thinking fast thinking's well
there there's clear overlap with Danny
Kahneman is is afraid to talk about the
brain I'm less afraid live work not that
I'm a neuroscientist not remotely but
I've somebody else done I mean you've
done the taking the neuroscience angle
honor does anybody else sort of paid no
attention to Danny just gone ahead see
if there's any system one system to in
the brain I I think that was really
talking about you know his characters
are if you were a little as fearful he
would be talking about the limbic system
and talking about the prefrontal cortex
and of course the evolutionary history
of the prefrontal cortex is a lot it's
we're just getting a decent prefrontal
cortex right in terms of evolutionary
time we have a terrific hot system and
we have a highly vulnerable Co system
but I think that he's talking about very
similar things his focus is the ways in
which system one messes us up and how
therefore we are yeah they're forgetting
an enormous mistakes that we make in my
own work I perhaps as a clinical
psychologist I've been much more
interested in the ways in which we can
regulate the system one and enjoy it and
at the same time keep the future and the
important goals in mind and
towards them so in a way I think he he
deals with very similar phenomena but
talks about what the risks for
decision-making are and I tried to focus
instead on what the possibilities for
enhancing long-term focus it's hard not
to characterize the two of you a little
bit in that Danny Kahneman comes across
as kind of a pessimist and you don't you
seem to be more optimistic about things
is that accurate do you think I I think
it's it's probably true on the whole
right the pessimist is saying things are
interestingly terrible yeah and the
optimists in this case is saying though
maybe we can fix this question from
Daniel is there any measure of happiness
this is not a question to any kind of a
task but a daniel says is there any
measure of happiness among the cases of
your longitudinal studies you know that
sort of success modes did that also map
under something you might call happiness
I think that well I mean to answer
Daniels question I'm not aware of
studies that combine self control
measures with happiness measures there
so I'm not aware of it but I think it is
safe to say an answer to what Daniel I
suspect has in mind that there's no such
thing as happiness if you don't enjoy
the hot system and there's no such thing
as happiness if you're not able to cool
it also so the the fundamental challenge
for all of us is how to make the
discriminations about when to go for the
marshmallow and when to forego it and to
to make that possible in a way that
you're in control of it I mean for me
the main interest in the research
is to help people be more agenting so
that they have choice if you don't know
how to delay of gratitude Olay
gratification you don't have a choice
if you don't know you have a choice
that's interesting one of the things
long now foundation takes as a guideline
is you know we want civilization to have
more options and I think a lot of the
idea of education is that people have
more options and it sounds like that
partly maps under what you're talking
about we're getting some notes from
alumni marshmallow
here's one from Sophie Sekulow Larry I
just mispronouncing that my sisters and
I we're subjects for the marshmallow
test as kids we all we did have you
investigated whether having siblings
influences the ability to delay
gratification and I did see by the way
in the film there was one case where the
two kids look like twins yes by the way
okay first of all anything having to do
with mapping of siblings onto whether
kids waited or not you mean what the
what the correlation terms this big
family kids don't know okay but I what's
the name of the questioner here you got
it Sophie
I mean how do you know that you've all
waited I mean I think I think one of the
one of the clear things about this is
people don't remember and don't know
whether or not they did and then they
tell themselves stories about whether or
not they
and and we part of part of part of what
made the research possible over the
years is that nobody really was told how
long they waited with one exception
I did have a very touching request from
the wife of someone who was in the study
and this guy was dying at an early age I
think he was in his 40s and his his
request was to find out how long he
waited I'm quite quite serious and
usually that's something that we would
have to go through an internal review
board and so on but I decided I'm
skipping the internal review board and I
told him and he had waited a nice decent
amount of time and had he had spent his
time sort of singing while he was but it
didn't seem to so this I'll come back
come up with something I'd love to meet
you afterwards come around well here's a
Helaman uh looks like Luigi writes my
fifty year old son Steve was one of the
subject here marshmallow study at
Stanford he is now an attorney with an
MBA works in finance in Boston has good
income and considerable savings in the
bank but lives in a small apartment with
his family he claims he never ate the
marshmallow
is that true how can I encourage him to
abandon delayed gratification and buy a
home the question is is that true cannot
say definitely true not know true to him
so that's what you're saying now begin
to two generations in cohorts a little
bit ruby made to ask what do you believe
is the influence of technology for
example iPhone overuse on delay ability
and young kids today how can delay
ability be enhanced in an age defined by
instant digital electronic gratification
well I think what's changed with the
information technology revolution is
that the number of of temptations and
the number of distractions that are
possible are enormous I don't think that
that in any way necessarily means that
the ability to self-regulate
is going down I think when I see my
grandchildren doing all this stuff with
the thumbs and so on I often worried
about what's gonna become of them but
they seem to be doing just fine my my
sense not of the basis of my six
grandchildren but on the basis of the
research that's available is that the
number of potential distractors keeps
multiplying but the growth in executive
function and executive skills also keeps
going because what the kids are doing
with their thumbs is actually quite
quite relevant to the growth of
executive control just I mean they're
not just they're maybe not texting and
maybe not Instagram but lots of other
things that they're doing for example
some of the games they're playing
very much cognitive games where you have
to keep a goal in mind and you have to
resist distractions I'll give you an
example from other people's research who
are starting a self-regulation and kids
and trying to see if computer games are
going to be helpful so you have for
example it's five-year-old kids a
situation where there's this they're
watching on the computer a cat on a
shrinking island and the water is
increasing the islands getting smaller
and smaller and you've got to do stuff
to keep the cat as dry as possible so
this is or you have a cat or other
organism running around and it's pouring
and your job is to keep the cat dry and
there's an umbrella floating around and
your job is to keep the umbrella under
running animal these are all cognitive
skills that are being learned where you
have to resist distraction keep your
focus on the thing and so on so I'm
saying it's a complicated question in
which there is on the one hand a growth
in the number of ways of killing time
and distracting yourself but also a
growth in executive function skills so
universities you've seen cohorts of
students coming through and looking at
them with your your eye do you see a
growth of sort of executive function
capability and undergraduates as they
pour through the decade it's hard to
separate whether I'm getting worse and
worse at whether they're getting better
from my point of view of my students
that more terrific all the time I mean
they were always wonderful but I am a
perfect example of miserable sampling
because I've had a life that's been
fortunate enough to be teaching at
Harvard followed by teaching at Stanford
for 21 years followed by teaching at
Columbia University for 30
three years old it's not exactly random
sampling Brendon ass this is I think a
universal question of parents what can
parents do to promote the development of
self control and is there a key age that
this sort of needs to be done by andechs
teachers probably also have this
question it's a terrific question that
the key age is from the moment that you
conceive or even think about conceiving
that's very young yeah it's very young
and I'm quite serious about this because
I think that one of the important
findings that comes out of the last 30
years of my brain Behavior Research is
that stress in young kids including in
utero but including in the first second
and third year of life is really
poisonous that high stress levels which
activate the heart system which slowed
the development of the patient and
constant stress is there a difference
yeah I'm talking about repeated
exposures to stress okay or a chronic
stressful environment are really perfect
for for slowing the development or
making the development of the core
system very problematic and having the
hot system going what do you think
I think the mechanism of that is that
stress automatically activates reflexive
behaviors you have strengthens when
there's nothing you can do ah you've got
a terrific situation for developing a
sense of helplessness because there's
nothing you can do and the stress is
primarily in the relations or parental
relationships or the stresses from
generation know the stresses from ever
from whatever it is that is producing
distress in the child it could be from
from parents who are fighting with each
other all the time studies suggests that
even raised voices register and and and
affect the sleeping life of the child so
I'm saying keep the stress levels low is
a good idea but if we get beyond the
first year or two keep your promises if
you want your children to be able to
delay gratification make sure that if
you if you make promises that you keep
them that it's build trust relationships
and secondly you know realize that
you're a model for the children and your
own behavior is going to be reflected
and a lot of the things that they do so
some of these things are banal they're
so obvious but they're also very
important keep your promises is that
also true of your threats absolutely
it's a problem I mean you could keep
your promises both for the good
consequences that can come and for the
for the punishments so the parental role
in a sense is this kind of reliable
continuity that you're putting out there
that the kid can count on some things
being there yeah and plus the plus the
modeling of strategies and how you live
your life that the kids can see
including your own self reward
strategies that is we all have as adults
we have access to endless goodies of all
sorts even even you know even if they're
not particularly nourishing so how we
deal with them is something that our
kids are certainly gonna pick up one of
the questioners here what is do you have
sort of marshmallow equivalent tests for
adults they're been desperate attempts
to make some but they're they really
have not succeeded it's is why I think
they're I mean I think it would take
another career to do that
I think a lot of people are trying to do
it no they are having careers a question
from anonymous are there any examples of
a society consciously shifting to a coal
brain policy and can it happen with
groups of people and we need now we're
getting and I think to sort of education
and how various groups and societies and
whatnot think about and do their
education and what's the variety there
how's work well I mean I think that
there are clear differences both within
societies and between societies in how
school systems work for example how
health care systems work there are
societies in which when women are
pregnant their social worker who
connects with the pregnant woman and
tries to be really a support you
mentioned switch windows yeah I think
that works well and my understanding is
that in Switzerland part part of the
service programs that are available
include a connection that's formed
between a health care worker who becomes
support and advisor and a helper to a
mother when she becomes pregnant and
that that continues for a number of
years for the critical first four or
five six years of life it would
certainly have a helpful effect if we're
thinking particularly of people who are
living without support services in very
high-risk environments in very stressful
environments and this speaks I presume
to you things like maternity leave and
now paternity leave practices and jump
companies yeah I think very clearly
speaks to things of that kind
Ryan asks is anything turned up in your
research related to your gender to the
boys and the girls yeah for years I
thought it doesn't make any difference
but when we look at the at the findings
curative lis there's actually a huge
sex difference which is the the girls
are much better honor
well well well does that does that
really surprise you no but I didn't
expect that much clarity frankly I
didn't expect it either I was surprised
by the finding because when we look at
it within studies we didn't see it and
we kept looking and then we stopped
looking and it's actually there when you
put it all together is there potentially
an age difference there that like your
daughters were getting that kind of no
no because it's with age controlled so
if you just yeah so apart that the boys
never get it I I think I know boys do
get it but they they may not get it as
early as girls this may apply in this
society level Brian Schulman asks how do
we cool responses in over reactions to
fears like terrorism and a large scale
especially in a context where fear
arousal driven messages keeps coming at
us it's a hard it's a hard question to
answer I think that the cool system if
you use your Co system you you realize
that President Obama was not so wrong in
what he said when he compared the number
of people who killed themselves by
stepping the wrong way into a bathtub in
the United States which i think was
something like 417 or something reported
cases of bathtub deaths by accident to
the to the number under a hundred under
50 under 30 who were killed by
terrorists in the United States I mean I
think he got into a lot of trouble for
making the comment I hope I'm repeating
it accurately
but I think that keeping a perspective
on it and realizing that it's like
airplanes fears airplanes are safer mode
of transportation than walking on the
streets but people are to have airplane
terror especially after a plane crashes
and 300 people get killed so I think I
think again it's a matter if you focus
on it it's terrifying if you think about
what are really the statistics it's a
it's cooler
but if you I mean it's dramatic Kevin
Kelly asks do groups of kids behave
differently in the test if they're
deciding as a team with teen
consequences is it does that been tried
with yeah as far as I know it hasn't
been studied but it's a very interesting
question what would be your prediction
my hypothesis is if you have a team and
the team forms with the goal of
self-regulating they they will work
pretty well together and be able to do
it if that if that's their goal and they
keep an eye on each other and yeah and
then they incur they offer mutual
support for it on the other hand if the
goal is to see how much you can do a lot
of the way in which the kid I describe
to open the Oreo cookies licked at the
ends I did it could be a terrific way of
instructing criminal behavior well I
mean I want to emphasize that the
liability and self-regulatory skills the
cognitive skills that make it possible
to take the future into account are
tremendously important but they can be
used for good or evil I mean they can be
used to to to have really the best crime
organization or the or the best
terrorist group they can be used or they
can be used for social good the ability
to play the long game is independent of
with yeah is independent of what the
goals are and whether they consistent
without moral values paul asks we saw a
number of factors that your
longitudinals
these were correlated with with the how
people how long they waited on the
marshmallows as wondered if there were
any factors he measured they were not
associated with delayed gratification so
you saw things that were associated were
there ones that you were interested or
surprised that that didn't connect at
all
well I I'm not surprised we actually
predicted it but one of the things we
find is that particularly in the Bing
sample which is a sample of kids clearly
from the top of the socio-economic
ladder it's it's very hard to predict
financial long-term financial outcomes
because there was you know everybody did
well everybody did well and yet there's
a there's a range and how well they did
and you don't even know what it means
that is is it is it a more successful
life to have made a fortune or to is it
a more successful life to be a middle
school teacher who you know went to
Stanford or went to Harvard but it's
devoting a life to teaching kids well it
does raise the question of because I
didn't see then there is a correlation
with the delay comfort people being
quote better parents well I think I
think that it's very hard to be a good
parent if you're not able to control
yeah yeah yeah it's very hard to be a
good parent and it's very hard to be a
good parent it's probably impossible to
be a good parent if you don't have any
self-control because for obvious reasons
Kevin Kelly yes has any of this been
tried on animals of any animals that
exhibit more self-control than others
yeah there have been a lot of studies of
animals lots of studies with animals I
mean not asking do some animals have
more self-control than others I mean the
self regulation enhances terrific
so yes animals self-regulate and most of
them their self-regulation patterns are
automatic so they're really part of the
animal's heart system but there are
there are things that that animals don't
or not do not seem able to do the
children are able to obviously again
question and longitudinal studies in
general Alexander Rose asked how did you
track your subjects for so long and what
percentage were you not able to keep
track of it's it's become much easier to
keep track of participants since the
since the information technology
revolution because we're in touch with
them by email and sign right
whereas before that with adverse changes
in the mail and so on it was a kind of
really very very difficult
so until email developed it was hard to
keep track of people but there's there
still a substantial cohort that we are
in touch with but I also think that all
the media attention makes the the chance
of doing really good research currently
I'm tough because these kids now adults
have been so studied and so you know in
the news that it becomes harder and
harder well there's a pulse that just
happened when your book came out I guess
last year and so suddenly there's a
bunch of recognition and public interest
in gone marshmallow test and what it in
what it means what's your sense of does
this mean there's now a new generation
of people doing sort of more refined
marshmallow tests than the research goes
on or people think that well okay that's
all done now we know what we need to
know and we can quit no I think I think
to me the most one of the most
interesting things about about the
research my students and I have done is
that it
comes in the last 15-20 years with an
enormous amount of work by other people
who are particularly interested in
seeing how what these kids are doing
registers in the brain so the question
of how does how does when you change the
appraisal of a cookie to focus on its
you know it's on its shape rather than
its on its taste what happens huh in the
brain and so I'm not gonna try to
summarize that go into the frontal
cortex well I mean the question of one
of the pathways and what is the
interaction between the different parts
of the brain that are involved in an
executive function has become a very hot
large topic in in both neuroscience and
social psychology and in the
collaboration between the two areas so I
mean my my long-winded answer is yes
it's a huge area now with a five-fold
increase in the number of studies that
that are going in in the last 15 or so
years ring guy asks schools are now
starting to quote measure grip what do
you think of this and is this something
that can be done and should be taught
with things I think I think it's
terrible and I yeah and I think Angela
Duckworth who is a friend and a
colleague you know with whom I've had a
lot of connections strongly agrees and
wrote a powerful piece on the topic in
the New York Times just saying quite
recently saying it's a disaster if
schools try to measure grit the toes so
don't do it on the other hand she
herself is of course trying to measure
great but we're trying to understand how
kids manage to wait for two cookies or
whatever
it would be terrible I think if this
were really turned into a test and had
the same kind of faith that things like
the SAT do my gosh so I'm all against
the use of this as a way of categorizing
kids because I'm enormous ly impressed
by the fact that while there are
correlations that I described briefly
you know in my short remarks there are
at least three different trajectories
there kids who are consistent as we
study them over the years there are kids
who begin with low self-regulation and
get better and better over the years and
there are kids who begin with high
self-regulation and get worse and worse
over the years so all three trajectories
are going the funding and the attention
has been on the consistent kids but
there are two lengths of to two funding
agencies less interesting trajectories
that to me is a psychologist as a parent
as a human being are more interesting
which are what on earth is going on when
kids start high which means we know what
they know how to do it and something is
happening to reduce you to reduce it and
what's what's going on and the ones who
start low and somehow make it keep going
the other way so if I had another
lifetime ahead I'd go for it my students
however are going for it and I want very
much to get the funding and the
opportunities to study those
trajectories so you're not in favor of
measuring grid as a sort of a filter for
various things but you're I'm against it
whether it's great or whether it's delay
of gratification if it's used to
categorize plants into fixed slots
because I think we're talking about sets
of skills that that are important to
have but that don't don't freeze people
into into into categories that the
mistake is to try to do that
well you're interested in training it in
schools and you mentioned the Kipp
schools I forget what kid
knowledge is power program and when it
says something that was organized by
Dave Levin and and the collaborator and
that is an attempt you know now with
about a hundred and fifty thousand kids
and schools all over the country to see
if the kinds of lessons that are coming
out of mind brain behavior research can
be incorporated into the curriculum and
it sounds like well they are are
deciding that it can and they seem to be
doing a very good job of it but mine my
own feeling is that rather than
measuring kids kids grit for example or
measuring the degree to which a school
is you know teaching kids to be gritty
that that each of the phrases that they
get used that it would be you know much
more interesting to have incorporated
into the curriculum even for young kids
how my brain works you know how I can
you know I change what I think and feel
and that if kids beginning at a young
age would have that it's at least as
important as sex education to have brain
education and to understand how we think
and feel and what how we regulate
ourselves or don't every day is that
troubling you're no I'm enjoying this
century Walter you've been around even
longer than I am at seventy
seven-year-old 8686
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I've seen a lot of weird [ __ ] go by
and a lot of stuff has gotten better and
we've seen our own selves and the people
we know our cohort change over time and
we've seen in your case the discipline
of getting more refined over time and
take on interesting problems and solve
some of them what do you think
an alert older person like yourself who
was interested in all of this sees that
and can transmit that say the younger
ones can't you know what's the advantage
of age in this kind of perspective if
any the what's the advantage of age of
in thinking about this whole domain and
acting on this domain the frame it a
little bit my sense is that older people
are more comfortable with long-term
issues and responsibility because
they've seen quite a few and there's a
lot of things that they know are just
distractions because they've seen so
many of them go by and they're it really
didn't matter after all so they get down
to a little more S&C type stuff and so
the long-term thinking and maybe
long-term behavior responsible behavior
it comes a little more naturally to a
person who's been around for a few
decades and someone who hasn't yet well
I mean I think age can do two things it
can it can give you perspective which is
what you're talking about yes and it can
give you Alzheimer's so
[Applause]
IIIi would like to also say a word for
as a scientist who take science
seriously I would like to put in a good
word for the importance of luck I think
I think luck is a very very important
factor and and how how the how life
plays out how do you train for luck 12
I'm gonna take still I'm gonna take your
question seriously because I think
there's luck and I think there's
recognizing luck
recognizing opportunity and so it isn't
just luck because a lot of people can
have luck and not even know it and maybe
if you don't have Alzheimer's maybe part
of what comes with aging is gratitude
and a recognition that one has been
lucky you know to live and not have
Alzheimer's so the the the good thing
about that is that it allows one to you
know to suspend some of the usual daily
pressures of the of the active ER here
is simply I mean let's put a hospital
one of them never let me decide practice
and say there's a phrase that I'm sure
many of you have heard which is you know
when you were young you build your
curriculum Vita and you're trying to you
know focus on that when you're older you
work on your obituary but that's I mean
that's quite serious I mean which is
your way you know where you're trying to
do things so that you get remembered
well and that okay so that that's long
term that is long term
and and now we are dealing with the
other interesting subject builder people
which is death in and the interesting
casino for short timers and short timers
on this are famous for being pretty
selfish you know you screw it and do
stuff and who cares on the other hand
most of the older people I know are the
they are short timers but they're the
opposite of irresponsible about that
what's that about is that just a bit you
area legacy building but I mean it's I
were reluctant to generalize because
guess so many ways of you know being
young in so many ways of getting old
it's you know that that that is
something happens when you're three four
five and six and there's something
happening probably when you get 70
something 80 something naughty something
no I think there's a lot that's
happening and I think one of the things
that's happening is that the brain
really is like everything else about one
is going through change and and the
change is is not one in which the number
of skills and so on is increasing but
where all kinds of things are weakening
so but I think that recognition also
gives can give a kind of understanding
about the finiteness of one's own lives
I mean you know we're all born as the
existentialist say with a death sentence
because that's gonna happen to everybody
but as you get older and older you
realize that's really waiting you know
that on the other hand we can be talking
about Woody Allen and his approach to
this which is you know I've always known
that everybody dies but I thought that
an exception would be made for me and
and so far it's work
which raises another question which is
rewards in the afterlife there are a
great many people who buy into systems
in which there's a kind of a caramel
which plays out either in later lives or
in afterlife and one is good in this
life in order to be rewarded in the
afterlife how does that play into any of
this well I mean I think what you're
saying is tremendously important and I
have no humor about it I think it's
tremendously important because I think
that what would happen in the last
century is that many people lost a
belief in an afterlife lost God in a
sense and that was the the crisis that
still hasn't gone away but that hit the
world after Darwin and where the
conception of human nature and who we
are shifted as we became part of
evolution without prospects about any
kind of afterlife and so on I think
that's very hard for very many human
beings to accept because what does it
mean it means you're an eyeblink you
know in your life and the world goes on
it's been around for [ __ ] forever
it's gonna go on that way probably
unless we blow it up or something in
which case who cares because every year
if you go you know to a National Academy
meeting there's more universes
discovered well galaxies discovered so
so if you asked what have I learned in
my lifetime I've learned increasingly
about the insignificance of it all
become in the sense that it's the most
significant thing because it's all we
got is life our life but on the other
hand in a broad perspective
we're talking about thinking long and
thinking big as as we chatted about
before the the main thing that's
increased in my lifetime from scientific
knowledge is everything has gotten
bigger there are more zeros on
everything it used to be the debates
where is the is the is the earth you
know
5,000 10,000 20,000 for millions of
years how long is this thing been around
you know and everything gets larger the
scope of the universe the nature there's
more and more zeros added to everything
and this I think really does change the
conception what makes us smaller in
context of that but then we also sort of
that we're the ones that can figure out
those zeros makes us think that we're
pretty big well yeah I mean we were both
pretty big and pretty small again that's
all we got so we'll come down to the
final fundamental question I guess is a
little bit can civilization past the
marshmallow test and the Oh climate
change might be as sort of a stand-in
for what the planetary scale calling for
delayed gratification grid all of that
stuff might apply what do you think well
I I think you correctly identified me as
an optimist I think you're quite right I
think that it is possible for for human
beings to be to feel and to be quite a
gent ik and to actually do gender course
I agenting to have agency I work you
know to be to have the agency instead of
being a victim Ursula instead of being
victims of their biographies of
evolution of their whatever and that if
if if we are agenting there are all
kinds of things that we can do to make
the world a better place to reduce so
see I can
to reduce the enormous inequity that
exists present is it ketching is this
sense of agency something that when more
people have it more people have it I
said again that more people is it
catching that I don't know if Topton ISM
is is or is not but this sense of we can
do something about even seemingly very
insuperable problems we can do something
is that I think that's a fundamental to
avoid depression and it's fundamental to
to keep going
so it's mental health but it also
relates to we actually do the deed can
you actually bear down on difficult
problems for decades at a time maybe
centuries at a time I see the climate
change issue as one planet scale
everybody is involved well 7 something
billion we caused it no it's up to us to
solve it oh it's not gonna be fixed in
any given a year or any given decade it
takes a century to do that which is
longer than most life spans at this
point so we're already talking about
something people acting beyond their own
lifespan maybe into their kids and their
grandkids do you see that is something
civilization is up to well I mean I I
think I think it is extraordinarily
difficult for any of us to really make
outcomes that are potentially far far in
the future become imminent and close and
powerful for us now I mean I talked
about my own struggle to make tobacco
which has an effect within a lifetime
something dividend potted up the bad
future of being that guy on the gurney
in the hospital and so part of what we
need to do is hot up the bad future of a
that's the fundamental message that I've
tried to convey in my remarks which is
if we want to be effective about
preventing long-term catastrophe and
enabling long-term positive outcomes
we've got to make the distant future
vivid hot and immediate and that's not
easy but it's not impossible and we can
do it through even through art we can do
it through drama I mean there are ways
to because we do have a prefrontal
cortex then we do have an imagination
and we can anticipate if this should be
possible and is possible I mean a gourd
did a pretty good job of it but then you
know he didn't get elected that's all
right
well I think you just stated the
function of the long now foundation
thank you for doing pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
you